i had this place next to my house where
i used to always go to get coffee and
sandwiches
like fresh bread is that the one you
took me to
yeah maybe yeah it was amazing yeah and
i i went the other day and it was it was
close during a normal day i think that's
weird i went back in the next day it's
closed again i'm like okay all right
what's going on here yeah i go back
yesterday it's gone
like they
they were building [ __ ] in it and i was
like what oh no
i was like
am i not supporting local business i've
been here so many times i i literally
like i must have given them more money
than any other customer potentially i
went here like every [ __ ] day right
and i was like how do i what do i do now
should have brought two sandwiches a day
i i did i literally did i died i bought
two every time i went and a coffee even
though the coffee was [ __ ] and
overpriced i bought it from there damn
you're the only person yeah you're the
only one you're the only the only one in
your neighborhood that i appreciate
am i the only one keeping this alive do
you guys not appreciate sandwiches uh
it's a really nice coffee store and they
they talk to me every time i go but it's
really awkward small talk but i can tell
for japan it's like super sincere yeah
yeah i'm like this is just a little bit
too like if you know you know it's
sincere when a a random japanese person
is talking to another random person yeah
and a foreigner on top of that it's like
is there a family owned coffee shop no i
feel like it is i've never heard of this
it being a chain or anything yeah and
they have it's nice they're really cute
they they always ask what i'm doing that
day and i always answer the same thing
yeah they ask any day and then one time
i was carrying like some camera gear and
they're like oh are you filming today
i'm like yeah
and over there they're like come on and
i'm like thanks friend yeah that's so
cute yeah it's really cute they're
really nice they do good coffee so now
i'm gonna go have to get their banshee
and buy their a little overpriced coffee
buy their stocks it's a
when
little
overpriced
like the good experience you get the
people who actually care about their
jobs there's nothing like yeah there's
nothing that brings the smiles to me
more than just seeing someone that just
really loves and cares for their job
even if it's like the small jobs you
know i'd rather give them pay a little
bit extra than starbucks to say [ __ ] you
to starbucks but yeah here's the thing
right did i talk about this on the
podcast last time no i didn't i rented
someone else i'm just trying to remember
who i've ranted to about what yeah and
i've definitely rented about this okay i
i don't want to always order [ __ ] from
starbucks right
but online i in the morning i i might
want a coffee and i want food with it
right i want lunch yeah so i want coffee
and a lunch and like nowhere in japan
does decent coffee and decent lunch it's
like pick up pick pick your pick your
priority do you want good coffee okay
the lunch is probably gonna be really
bad or they won't have anything yeah do
you want good lunch okay they probably
don't have coffee and if they do it's
like just black americana yeah and then
they give you some like sugar packets
and stuff
yeah it's like sour as well yeah this is
privileged by the way this is privileged
the conversation but um
like starbucks is like the only place
that does it yeah on ubereats so i'm
like
i don't want to buy starbucks but
they're the only one who does it if a
competitor comes up and it's a smaller
person i swear to god i'll give you all
my money just please someone else yeah
well i'll tell you the thing that annoys
me about ordering stuff from starbucks
here in japan uh especially now after
going to america and having the
privilege of ordering starbucks and
coffee
in america especially la which is oh my
god the amount of options you get in
america just blows japan out the water
right like japan have like the bare
basic options with all of their coffee i
would expect this like most most of the
most of the options i don't really give
a [ __ ] about but in japan the really
thing the big option that really annoys
me and that's why the reason i've really
ordered coffee from starbucks is because
i want a hot coffee even if it's like
the summer most of the time i want a hot
coffee in starbucks in starbucks you can
only order one size on ubereats i don't
know why that is but really yeah if you
try to order hot coffee in starbucks
like the latte or something every hard
coffee there's no size option there's
only one size and it's the smaller size
and i'm like and it's japan's small size
as well so it's not it's no way a decent
size it's basically an espresso yeah
yeah but for some reason their iced
latte their iced coffee it's it's got
all that like the tall grande venti size
but the hot coffee has only one size and
i'm like why is that the case what do
what just go what is going on starbucks
super easy in japan and then and then
like the dichotomy of spending a month
in [ __ ] la or whatever you go on the
ubereats app and the thing is like a
[ __ ] character customization screen
holy [ __ ] that's every option possible
oh yeah that was that was dumb yeah you
just want one coffee and you have nine
options if you choose each one you're
like what the [ __ ] yeah the moment you
choose either hot or cold it opens to
another page yeah it's like 17 options
i don't know what half of this [ __ ]
means like you like order you like go in
the order screen to get to the order
screens
they're like what molecular level of
milk do you want tell us tell us the
atomic the atomic weight of the milky
way it's like what do you mean but you
know yeah but all of these customization
is [ __ ] in japan like if you want to get
like actually stuff like customized like
like i think we said before if you order
subway in japan okay one you shouldn't
be doing that yeah but if you do because
somebody just want a sandwich you're sub
right yeah
you can't order toasted online
yes you if you order a subway sandwich
you cannot get it toasted you have to go
to the store which to me is like
what is the barrier here like are you
worried that it'll be like soggy when it
gets to me i'm i'm okay to sign up for
that risk like i want the cheese melted
like i i don't care i'll heat it up
myself or some [ __ ] i don't know but
maybe you're the rare breed and most
japanese people are just like no well i
think because they don't know it's like
an option because no one goes to subway
here yeah that's true
sandwiches are called yeah i've only
seen like one subway here in tokyo or
something like that there's not many at
all no it's not like uh because why
would you [ __ ] order for it so it's
really bad it's really great it's really
bad yeah i will admit like it's it's not
great in america but it's leagues better
than the one yeah here like even
mcdonald's as well like the one thing i
want from mcdonald's with my [ __ ]
meal sometimes is mcflurry and there's
only one mcflurry here there's only one
option mcflurry and i see oreo mcflurry
and that's the worst [ __ ] mcflurry
out of every option you could possibly
choose japan choose to put the oreo
mcflurry on ubereats am i the only
things oreos taste bad i just think
audio oreos don't taste good i just
think they the biscuit is [ __ ] quality
yeah and the stuff is the only thing
keeping the together yeah literally and
metaphorically i mean it doesn't like
make me you know [ __ ] jesus i like it
it's just it's it's it's such a mid
cookie i think it's below mid
there are made cookies tim tams are mid
yeah like [ __ ] off
i just think that like
oreos are
way below that yeah i think that the per
the best mcflurry is just
just give me the [ __ ] one with the
little chocolate like crushed sprinkles
in it like you know where they just get
a piece of chocolate i think i've
ordered a mcflurry maybe twice in my
life i like it in the uk a lot so don't
i have no say on this one in the uk it
goes hard really i think so well the
problem with like oreo mcflurries is
that unlike say some other chocolate
bits where it's actually like physical
like nice solid bits of chocolate or
honey cookies or whatever the oreo
mcflurry is just like like the cookie
just turns into [ __ ] powder right
right so so the the powder just blends
in with the ice cream and i'm like this
is awful because i want like i there's
no clear distinction between where the
ice cream starts and where the cookie
starts you know because it's just ice
cream cookie now at this point i think i
think you're expecting a little too much
high quality from something from
mcdonald's
no no flurries are normally pretty damn
good yeah if it works yeah right
anything but oreo mcflurry's [ __ ]
slaps what yeah what are the other
what's your favorite one i just i'm
basic i like the dairy milk option yeah
yeah yeah dairy milk yeah dairy milk
it's just like bits of dairy mulch yeah
it's more than crunchy the crunch of the
curry option or the or the eminem
options those all all great all
fantastic
m1 out of the two times i ever ordered
mcflurry that was yeah yeah but oreo
mcflurry's why japan why why why why why
would you choose oreo at least the
machine always works here i've never
been to mcdonald's it wasn't working yet
that's true
i didn't i didn't know that's true
that's true that's that's that's we got
it good we got it good that's that's the
trade-off
is it is it a trade that's like that's
like the monkey poor trade-off yes your
ice cream machines always work but you
i'm like this is this is hell no this is
[ __ ] hell
the ultimate choice this man had the uh
the uh the the story with the black
thunder uh black thunder snacks yeah
those are really good i see like i don't
know do you like black thunder i
actually really like like that yeah
that's black thunder again like thunder
is like those like japanese yeah like
chocolate bars it's kind of like a
crunchy yeah okay no it's not it's not
no let me let me google this right now
because like they have more options in
mcdonald's itself they i'm talking about
yeah i don't know if they still do it's
definitely i don't know it's it's it's a
chocolate bar if you come to japan you
try it's pretty good and if you go to
hokkaido they have a white chocolate
version yeah but they don't call it
white thunder they call it white oh this
oh yeah
yes
thunder
i never understood that